i wanted to put this book out in the
universe for other people to read
to to show them that there are good
people doing kind things for others
all over the place it's what it what
it's what unites us you know i really
think that kindness begets kindness
and those that do good things for others
it gets passed along
right
one of the things that i really loved
about the book is when i when i do my
show every day
i try to do it with a little bit of a
smile on my face i try to do it so that
people don't feel depressed after about
the news
i'm not trying to just bludgeon
everybody so that they're stuck
watching which is pretty much what cnn
and a lot of the other places are doing
so i guess first how did you kind of
come to that place
where telling people some of the good
stuff uh actually mattered to you
i've been telling good news stories for
many years now i do a feature on fox
news radio called the dean's list
and it's a 60-second feel-good story
about
a person doing kind of things for
someone else
or you know doing something that brings
sunshine into someone's day
so i've been doing that for a very long
time and i always thought to myself i
would love to make this into a book
where i could dive into these stories
each make them a chapter so this was
that
this was that book i started working on
it before the pandemic
but i wrote most of it and did a lot of
the interviews during the pandemic
um and more than ever even though we
were socially distancing from each other
i was finding these stories
all over the place of people doing
wonderful things for other people
we were adapting as human beings um you
know
you saw people doing car parades for
birthdays i got one of those my husband
did that for me for my 50th birthday
um so and the other part of this was
you know i wanted to put this book out
in the universe for other people to read
to to show them that there are good
people doing kind things for others
all over the place it's what it what
it's what unites us you know i really
think that kindness begets kindness
and those that do good things for others
it gets passed along
right so but what i didn't realize dave
is that i was the one that was going to
get the most out of writing this book
because i was talking to these wonderful
people during the darkest
time for our family and and getting
light and goodness from all of these
stories and interviews that i was doing
and every day you know i would i'd take
my
oldest son matthew for a walk and that
would be our topic of conversation he'd
be like
mom who'd you talk to today tell me the
story and i would tell him the story of
the napkin notes dad who wrote napkin
notes for his daughter
emma when she was just a little girl and
how he continued
doing that even though he was diagnosed
with cancer and thought he might not
live to see her
graduate so he wanted to make sure he
wrote napkin notes
for hundreds of school days in case they
lost him
he's still here and i talked to him and
i talked to emma
and so those are the people that
brightened my day when we were going
through such dark
times uh so that's the
ironic part of this is i got so much out
of writing this book more that more so
than i ever thought i would
yeah so i want to dive into a couple of
the stories because there's some really
great stuff in there but i'm curious
when you were
pitching the book and bringing it to
your publishers and everything is is
selling a book that's
that's so positive is that tough for
those guys because if you just look at a
bookstore you know
front front area what's in the window i
mean
it's all basically depressing stuff you
know the world's coming to end
the pandemic's going to kill you trump
tried to kill you somebody else is
coming to get you you know blah blah
blah
blah it's a tough sell i'm not gonna lie
and what i didn't tell you is before the
dean's list happened i did a good news
story on fox news a show called
happening now with my friend jane
skinner
um and she was the one that came up with
the dean's list because she thought you
know the news is so terrible we need
something bright and cheery and you do
the weather and
and you know the weather is is a lot of
times it's mostly sunny but sometimes
it's stormy but why don't we work on a
good news story that we can use as a
kicker we call it a kicker in the
business
and so we started doing that on
television
but the news kind of like took over and
the dean's list got killed more often
than not
but i was you know she was always a
cheerleader of it so the moral of the
story
is you know what sometimes the good news
doesn't sell
um but i think now more than ever
we need these stories dave you know i
really think that we need to hear these
hopeful
good stories about trying to be a better
human being
um and so that's my message and i will
tell you
that i got a lot of people saying to me
okay your book is coming out
when are you going to stop with the
cuomo stuff because we need the right
choice
right right be like hi i'm the sunny
girl who brought you this the most make
your own sunshine stories
and i said you know what i'm both why
can't i be both because i
am both i'm still the half the glasses
half full i'm still the mostly sunny
girl
i'm also an advocate who wants to shine
sunlight as a disinfectant so
you know i think the advocacy can also
be making your own sunshine
um so you know trying to balance both of
those things is
i can be both at the same time but i'm
not gonna lie sometimes
the good news stories are a tough sell
excellent use of the metaphor
with sunshine as the best disinfectant
that fully works with the book
um give me give me like two stories that
you that really particularly
moved you i i can pick one or two but
but if you got some that are
right off the top of your head well it's
funny because everyone tells me a
different story
that they love and that's what i love
about it is that
you know someone will say well i loved
you know
the the carrie blasey story so i'll tell
you that one that was the first one the
first
um one of the first interviews that i
did during the pandemic and carrie and i
became very close friends
afterwards simple story her daughter
uh was diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
forgive me type 2 diabetes what's the
more serious one i
forgive me um i don't want to screw this
up
so i'm going to get my book right this
is this is impressive an author actually
going to the source i like it well
wait i've got let's see who can find it
first i don't want to screw it up
because there's
there's a really okay there's a really
there's two types of diabetes
and the one that she has is the really
serious one type one
type one okay and that's why it's
important because
carrie is a big advocate for type one
diabetes because
that's you know not to say that type 2
is is not a serious illness as well
um but type 1 is when you're really
really
constantly concerned about your child
every day they take her
you know her measurements her glucose
levels she's got a special
you know uh a a special portal on her
body that has to be
you know her insulin has to be just
right the right level
so having said that um carrie put a sign
on her door
saying that she had a person who was
compromised living in her house and as a
person who lives with ms i can totally
identify with that
at the beginning of the pandemic we
didn't know how bad it was she didn't
want the virus
anywhere near her daughter her
compromise daughter so she put a sign on
the door that said
if you have any deliveries leave the
package here don't ring my doorbell i'm
not opening up the door
just leave it here and i will sanitize
the package and bring it in
so a wonderful fedex driver sees the
sign
and and says oh goes back to his fedex
truck
they see this by the way on a camera he
doesn't know that he's being filmed they
have one of those nest cameras on there
on their doorstep
he goes back to the fedex truck grabs uh
some wipes
and wipes the package he smudges the
print on the package
and and thinks to himself oh i don't
want them to
wonder why the package is smudged so he
writes a note saying
i saw your note on the door i sanitized
the package have a great day
he didn't expect anything from that she
saw the video of this kind
fedex driver and thought to herself wow
he went
the extra mile took the extra step to do
this for my family
and her husband was the one who said you
should put that out on social media
maybe he'll get a raise or fedex will do
something nice for this driver
and she put it on social media it went
viral
fedex certainly you know saw that uh
justin bradshaw by the way is the fedex
driver
and as it turns out justin has a little
girl that when she was born was a
preemie and they had to take care of her
and they were worried about her so his
backstory
sort of reflects upon you know why he
was doing what he was doing
so that's the story of carrie blasey and
her daughter emma
and the wonderful fedex driver justin
who did a kind
thing that deserves all of our attention
and that's why i started the book with
that chapter
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell